jennifer walters also known as she-hulk
is one of the biggest marvel superheroes
who has yet to appear in live action
but that's about to change in the near
future this lawyer-turned-superhero who
gains her powers via a gamma-irradiated
blood transfusion from her cousin
bruce banner will be coming to the mcu
the highly anticipated disney plus
series will star actress tatiana maslany
in the leading role
she hulk has a long history in the
comics the legendary stan lee
helped create the character alongside
artist john buscema
four decades ago she hulk was originally
created for a very specific reason
namely to make sure marvel comics would
have the rights to a female hulk
counterpart
there was concern that the producers of
the 70s incredible hulk tv series might
create one first
now that mazlani is officially she-hulk
a lot of fans want to know how the
character's distinct appearance will be
brought to life
when you look at maslany it might not be
immediately obvious to you what the
slender 5 foot 4 inch actress might look
like as she-hulk
now what she'll look like is attorney
jennifer walters ready to argue a case
that's easy but as an angry giant green
superhero
well that's a bit harder to imagine can
you tell me what the angry angel looked
[Music]
like
acclaimed fan artist boss logic has come
through with a stellar interpretation of
how she could appear
his depiction of maslany as she-hulk
manages to incorporate
everything you could want from the
character the muscles
the outfit and yes the green skin it's
also cool that he included an image of
maslany from orphan black in the
background to show the difference
between regular walters and her
superhero counterpart
in fact the more you look at bosslogic's
image and think about maslany's previous
works
the clearer it becomes why she makes so
much sense as she hulk
maslany has a background in both comedic
and dramatic acting for one which could
be extremely important since
historically
she hulk is a comic book character known
for her meta humor
even going so far as to break the fourth
wall years before deadpool started doing
it in comics and films
it's over go home
maslany's small size in real life will
allow her to physically embody the
equally small
insecure side of walters but then as
someone who has played various clones in
orphan black she can easily use subtle
body language cues to show just how
different walter's personality becomes
when she transforms into she-hulk the
character of she-hulk isn't known for
having multiple personalities
but the duality of her nature is
something maslany is well suited for
at least as walters figures out her
powers and what they mean
she-hulk has gone through a lot of
different incarnations since her first
debut in the first issue of the savage
she-hulk in 1980.
the character that stanley and john
busama created back then was triggered
by rage
much like bruce banner but this
depiction didn't last long
far more popular was the version of
she-hulk written by john byrne wherein
walters saw her confidence bloom when
she became green
this depiction of the character was
self-aware comedic and has influenced
most other takes in the years since
it's entirely possible that the disney
plus series will pull influence from
those two eras
according to deadline sitcom director
cat cuero is involved in the show while
rick and morty's jessica gow is being
eyed to lead the writer's room all
of which implies a comedic focus unlike
the burn era though where in walters was
for all intents and purposes
permanently in she-hulk form it's
possible that maslany won't be green
all of the time or even most of the time
it's very likely that a big focus will
be paid to jennifer walters the lawyer
in which case the show may pull some
influence from the comic book run by
writer attorney charles sol
who put a lot of emphasis on that
element and specifically examined
super heroism through the lens of the
law
in one story seoul featured she-hulk
facing off against tony stark
a conflict which involved her physically
battling his security
while also outsmarting him with her
legal mind
time will tell exactly how maslany will
look as she-hulk and we can't wait to
see it
marvel's she-hulk is still in the early
stages but it will eventually be
available on disney plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one